well I can learn to this video Sammy
know we'll send me know whoops come on
just one move it's nothing nothing too
difficult semi Noah it's no name in them
okay yeah this is a modern defense it
should be three is a book line geax
takes you five en this is rather often
played in comparison but it's nothing
terribly grateful black but certainly a
playable playable set up why this
routing is Bishop to d3 really that
early okay let's see what happens okay
the the thing that black probably wants
to do is to put a bishop I know I and
Bishop only five is not going to happen
my main objection with this early mf5 is
of course that the e6 square is is so
much weakened maybe it's um it's not
such a big deal that time yeah it's it's
it's very M it's a very comfortable
position for white in any case very hard
to ever see wide losing him but it's
also difficult difficult to see how I
should when admit that let's see so I
move like f form is not very great
because of ruby three what I would like
to do is actually to play the rope to e6
but that's not really leading to too
much
that's very either that's really not
much going on here I can play room p6
not like terrible but ok let's just play
a strengthening new ideas play baby
Queen B 1 and the trade of roofs but I
can play rookie too actually why didn't
I do that that's much better rookie one
wasn't nothing move if he cannot try it
anyway I mean he can but this gives me
the you file a rookie one was a bit
silly I should've played rookie two in
the first place
so I can put it only six now ever want
okay so if i go Queenie to do we create
Red Queen's probably it probably has the
trade and rook f 6m 22 really exchange
everything off yeah but here isn't the
six hanging or our AC going for the
counter play is probably going for the
counter player with rook with Bishop d41
like rookie to look F 3 on what exactly
rook f3f bishop we form don't have this
should be formed where's the where's the
drawback I don't see it
okay f king g2 I guess getting out of
the pin so that I can go F form yeah now
I can reroute to e6 to g4 than 36
yeah that's not not very much of course
but I point is upon f3 we should be six
yeah well now I put it on your six why
not and f3 hard too hard to play without
the move and now bro maybe look you fall
and each form trying to create a new
weakness he goes gee for for activity a
platform and then aged 3 this is this
will definitely fall apart this was a
better defense but now h5 is a new
weakness how to is that way to put
pressure I know is trying for counter
play them
maybe okay la for I should play anyway
Bishop d7 to annoy him yeah maybe maybe
I can do this do this once I've got
Bishop yet now we should be angel check
so Luke checks or Bishop takes is the
difference it's car driving is seven
coming but I can go to g4 so I will take
with this should I put it actually King
rook age 8 is not good Here I am that's
not ideal and I've goodness I haven't
probably has that late played exactly
grade check
check
so I will clip a and C Paul and I have
the deep on to to push and this is even
I'm getting the b6 porn it's very very
important
check
yep the a pawn this Maya a winner at the
end the only thing is there some stupid
meeting net or whatever I don't think so
check
we go to see seven churches which is
save check over here whatever
check check check check yeah okay six
seconds
there's a reason there is no stalemate
yeah this was um kinda weird because
there was not much going on and then he
played this d3 move which okay that
shouldn't lose ya i'm not saying that
but okay the issue is not really this
but I thought you should take be too
maybe yeah if he takes now Rooker d6
Bishop Devoy is ok but but in the first
place I mean you can just go here and
it's a draw I mean without any problem
because it will be a rogue trade and
then nothing happens this this I mean
you often want to play actively and this
was active but I'm just I'm just keeping
my my stuff here and I'm a porn up it's
just um just very convenient to play I
think also he shouldn't have moved the
points here in the first place because
ultimately at term it gets even it gives
him even more weaknesses and here this
this end game is very borderline
probably probably it is losing project
is I mean check and here chera certainly
may be there are ways to improve on my
pleasure with this little time but I
think I kept kept the win at hand all
the time he definitely um does not need
to do this just play we gave six and
trade off roofs nothing's happening okay
thanks for watching